some breaking news out of washington u.s
president joe biden is officially
revoking
a trump administration move to designate
yemen's houthi
movement as a terrorist organization
let's go live now to our white house
correspondent
uh kimberly halcott who can tell us more
kimberly so uh they're getting rid of
the terrorist designation but they're
going to keep a close eye on the houthis
nonetheless
yeah there's no question that this is
something that the white house was under
pressure to do particularly from the
international community
that it is now re-engaging with and as
part of its recalibration
with its relationship in the region
including saudi arabia
there's a lot of pressure to remove this
designation now as you point out the
state department has made clear that it
no way
condones the houthi actions in fact the
state department has called this
and the actions at times reprehensible
still what the concern was is the
humanitarian crisis
and the fact that a group said that this
designation
of the houthis as a terrorist
organization was affecting the
aid that gets into yemen as a result
of the fact that uh this is a country
that is on the verge of a very dire
crisis with respect to famine the fact
that there is a country and a population
dependent for its survival on not only
those commercial imports into the
country but also
in this humanitarian assistance so this
is something
that was lifted as a result of those
concerns but at the same time the state
department watching very closely
but again this is something that not
just the international community but the
u.s congress has also been
pressuring the biden administration on
given the fact that there have been
grave concerns about the relationship
with saudi arabia
the saudi-led conflict and the fact that
the united states has already frozen
some of their arms sales this is sort of
an extension of that recalibration of
the u.s relationship
in the region our white house
correspondent kimberly hellcat there
live in washington kimberly many thanks
indeed